chérie il ya deux personnes qui font des
live c'est benoît paire et stanislas
wawrinka lors ces deux immenses
champions voilà de tennis il était en
live sur un star et ils ont commencé à
parler de paddle tennis alors paddle
tennis c'est comme le tennis mais c'est
dans une salle centre le squash et le et
le tennis en fait un et de ping pong et
pendant leur live j'ai comme le
sentiment qu'ils m'ont un petit peu
charrié donc je vais vous montrer voilà
ce qui s'est passé vous allez me dire ce
que vous en pensez
et on aura les personnes présentes c'est
parti parce que toujours paddle j'ai un
petit peu je suis pas très bon mais
j'aime beaucoup ça j'adore ça tu sais
qui c'est qui m'a chauffé tout à l'heure
sur ça qui c'est qui va chauffer sur
quoi c'est cyril hanouna qui m'a chauffé
heures sur quoi au paddle
parce qu'en fait on faisait idée le truc
le 3g faire ouais
du coup on s'est parlé vite fait et il
dit mais tu sais on pas de seniors au
plafond il pense qu'il est pense que
c'est diom non valable et je vous le
dise appareils de molière praticiens il
paraît que tu as battu au ping pong
abattu dans son émission sur la petite
table de ping-pong battu premier à 3 il
semble acquis mais battu mais mise à
part ça si toi si toi tu es mort et sous
la pression lui les monstres eu avec la
pression vous entendez ce qu'a dit
stanislas wawrinka c'est un champion qui
a gagné des grands chelems tout ça n'est
pas un et la gagner ah ouais c'est pas
un rat loi d'un stanislas wawrinka vous
vous dire c'est saison mais je vous le
dis c'est un décès ces assisses effet le
top 5 1 c'est pas à eux
j'ai pas pris un tocard mon stack
d'amour mon stand amour scan de man stan
déjà merci merci d'être là c'est un
plaisir merci l'invitation maintenant
mais ça m'a fait plaisir stan j'ai eu
l'impression avec benoît paire que vous
étiez un petit peu en train de me
charrier concernant mes capacités
tennistiques et mes capacités de paddle
benoît paire et là je sais lui pour moi
c b le principal accusé qu'est mon frère
déjà répondre maintenant répondre à ça
en fait
vas-y moi je pense que on ne charrie pas
forcément pour ton niveau qui je ne
connais pas ton niveau mais ta façon de
faire une fois une chose est tout de
suite français était le dieu ou
stade
alors moi j'ai appris que vous proposez
après on va donner la parole à l'accusé
benoît paire gérer les noms benoît
benoîte à paris a dit et j'ai entendu
dire que tu avais dit que tu m'avais
battu au ping pong rappelle-toi rappelle
toi chez toi qu'on allait l'emmener les
proies de l'ads avec les voitures comme
je t'ai battu nom alors je vais vous
dire la vérité on a il n'y avait pas de
lumière chez moi on a dû aller dehors
mettre la table dehors et allumer les
phares de la voiture pour voir la balle
et benoît tout dans tout ça tout ça t'a
bon tout ça ta bouche prend les
téléspectateurs en à témoins mais benoît
frère c'est moi qui ai gagné et il y
avait deux témoins il y avait un copain
mois qui s'appelle franck que je peux
appeler tout de suite et on avait appelé
quelqu'un qui suit après sa défaite et
sept personnes et là c'est gaël monfils
qui est là je demande s'il vous plaît un
gaël monfils de venir à la barre qui
s'est passé entre benoît paire qui a
gagné salut moi c'est rythme a appelé
tout de suite après ces résultats je
vient d'éclater benoît est bien mais
arrêtez arrêtez benoît au thème tu as
perdu tu as perdu ta y avait trop de
pression et la raison tan y avait une
pression de ouf et j'ai gagné ce match
j'ai tout témoin j'ai gagné mon fils et
j'ai le mec qui était très belle qui est
un mec avec nous je me rappelle mais je
me rappelle surtout qui les a appelés
quand je suis parti parce que tu avais
perdu maison il a gagné
non benoît benoît si tu veux on va
refaire cette partie moi ce que j'ai à
vous proposer
en tout cas parce que moi ce que je vous
composer c'est qu'après le confinement
on fasse un double gaël et moi au paddle
tennis contre stan et benoît on
retransmet sur ces mythes ont fait venir
du public et on donne tout la recette
pour l'association des hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france arrête ses
partenaires est ce que je t'aime ich
thanh tai fook quoi on fait cela nettoie
contre gaël et moi au paddle tennis on
fait vraiment un truc on leur transmet
sur ces huit as et à l'open de tennis
voilà c'est fait moi c'est fait c'est
fait pour moi c'est bon c'est bon repos
star
je sais que je suis de loin le mont en
bon tous mais c'est pas grave c'est
vraiment traîné je vais m'amuser quoi le
problème
mecheri les chéris d'ailleurs question
de question pour les trois qui de nous
quatre a le plus petit mental à votre
avis ouais c'est moi c'est moi je
réponds je retourne l axe là dedans
c'est pour ça que j'adore ce nom mais
les mecs on va se le faire ce truc là
moi je vous raconte un truc et je dis la
vérité il y en a qu'un seul qui m'a
battu sur une table deux ministres ont
qu un seul au monde et il est là c'est
gaël bas je l'intéressais là et c'est le
seul qui m'a battu aux milices au mini
ping pong je le dis voilà franchement
c'est vrai en revanche gaël
aujourd'hui je vais tout balancer sur
ces gens là j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
un jour il est venu à la maison on a
fait sur dix épreuves
tu te rappelles de ça des jeux
olympiques sur dix épreuves ping-pong
baby-foot flipper voilà on mettait une
balle dans une poubelle qui est arrivé
numéro un c'est tout ce que je vais
tacler juste une note
voilà on était dix chez gagné mills
arrivait numéro de danse en fait le
meilleur mais non mais non pas dans le
tennis il est monstrueux les mecs google
d'ailleurs il est monstrueux bah c'est
pour ça que je me suis mieux avec lui tu
crois quoi moi je regarde moi les mecs
qui va aller à la buvette moi vous ou un
ensemble d qui me dit voilà bien tu m'as
un petit coup de raquette terminée non
mais je te dis oui jean michel mr la
honda n d'attention pour nos mouvements
merci d'être là des gains web
aujourd'hui cyril moi je vais vous
donner une donnée objective ça fait pas
très longtemps que j'ai pas d'elle vous
avez pris 3 au cours de marches il ya
presque trente mille joueurs de paddle
je viens d'aller sur le site officiel de
la fédération française de paddle vous
êtes 4650 neuvième joueur français vous
étiez 5000 6000 il ya un mois avait fait
un bond de presque 2000 places en un
mois donc la bâche mans qui se passe
plus voilà c'est officiel c'est bravo
cyril tu fais des bons pendant le
confinement entre bravo
[Rires]
belle et mais je joue bien quand je joue
pas tout quand je joue je crois
l'espace d'une source soit est monté et
donc sa bombe mais bon on va parler un
peu tennis mine de rien il y aura par
roland garros donc peut-être en
septembre mais moi moi j'ai eu une idée
pourquoi on fait par roland garros comme
on va pas pouvoir avoir de joueurs
internationaux peut-être qu'ils ont fait
est à pouvoir l'en france pour coiffer
par roland garros qu'avec des français
est celui qui gagne le garros il a gagné
roland garros 2020 on sait qui c'est qui
va s'en rappeler
on sort on aura aux gaels où benoît sort
au doigt mais qu'est ce que tu as gagné
tu as déjà gagné roland garros ô combien
1 sans rigoler combien tu as déjà gagné
combien tu vas gagner trois tournois du
grand chelem un stade c'est beau c'est
monstrueux c'est monstrueux il est
monstrueux est dans la tête il est fort
tanon stan c'est un des après on va dire
et il le sait stan après forcément je
pense djoko rafa est forcément rogers
pour moi stan c'est voilà c'est le
quatrième plus grand joueur dans la tête
vraiment de l'histoire stan c'est stan
domaine c'est c'est quelqu'un qui a un
mental hors du commun qui c'est vrai un
petit pouce franchement qui pousse ses
adversaires dans der franchement
exceptionnel et surtout lui qui a une
attitude de guerrier exceptionnel et ça
et dos et que sur la grande aberration
par rapport à ça mais votez benoit je
voulais dire benoît et égalise vous avez
cessé un talent exceptionnel et moi je
vous dis il y en a un que vous doublez
payer parce que je vous ai dit il y en a
un ou deux qui va perdre au paddle est
en train de vous deux qui va gagner
roland garros je sais pas quand je sais
pas où mais il va le gagner
vous voulez parce que je vous ai dit
aujourd'hui jolie tête jolie peut-être
pas dans le couscous
je touche ma vie ni des mecs voilà
hockey qui se perdent au paddle et qui
gagne pas non plus ouais c'est possible
il y en a qui peut occuper
[Rires]
voilà pourquoi j'aime ce bel et benoît
juste 0 tu sais que tu ne dois 500
balles je le dis aux téléspectateurs tu
me dois 500 balles est ce que est ce que
je t'ai pas dit il ya deux jours que je
te rendrai sentence verrai où l'engin
c'est un mec clean et qu'est ce que j'ai
je t'ai dit je ne veux pas fait moi ce
tout ce que ce match de paddle stan et
toi contre gars et les mois et je veux
dire je m'en fous on remet les 500 euros
pour l'association c'est sûr et certain
c'est fait c'est fait ouais mogil ce que
je voulais dire c'est que au delà leur
disponibilité et leur gentillesse que
tous les spectacles et les
téléspectateurs ça ce qu'on a ici que
trois champions exceptionnels et qui
font rêver le public parce qu'au delà
d'être des joueurs hors pair grâce à
leur mental leur combativité c'est des
gens moi je les adore parce qu'ils font
rêver sur le terrain il a jamais
franchement pas extraordinaire et ben
ouais mon envie je voulais viendront joe
cole était très bon mais vous l'avez
battu homing quand même cyril alors
quand je lis alors je te le dis stan de
gauche les défoncer au mini bingo
mais j'étais défoncé toi tu es ce que je
vais dire djokovic ont une fois qu'on a
fini jeudi excuse-moi ferro m'ont fait
pas le même sport je sais pas quoi tu
joues tu es rentré chez était comme ça
il y avait la gueule ambiel djokovic
peut tenir
il a fait tout le monde la déchetterie
une tannée comme jamais et un racheteur
ni donc amené moi vos skis zalila les
nadal federer et djoko des années moi
toute cette bande de loustics lac mono
creux qu'est ce qu'un sale flamand
les mecs est pour l'instant ce que je
vois c'est que les résultats sont là ok
bon raid et chérie je vous dérange pas
je vous aime fort merci stade mercier ou
benoist merci mon guide est formidable
et j'ai hâte de vous revoir parce que
vous ne manquez grappes d'accord et vous
venez tous à la maison après un dea
qu'on n'est plus confiné obligé tous
fait des gros bisous bas salut les
frérots assez merci et bravo